[Music]
okay everybody I am really excited
because I had such a good talk with this
man last time he was on this is his
second time on my show he's the first
person from better call Saul to be on my
show twice which is really cool
Michael mando aka nacho aka Ignacio is
back how you doing Michael how you doing
Steve so nice to be back and thank you
for having me
yeah man this is just exciting because
you know it's crazy because since I last
talked to you I really talked to you at
the beginning of the season where we saw
where nachos character was and now the
season has literally just ended so I
just have a lot of my mind because
there's just been so much going on with
nacho especially in this episode but I
wanted to ask you first what I think a
lot of people have been debating is like
the exact relationship status of nacho
and Mike in this season and we see them
reunite where do you think nachos head
is on Mike do you think he actually
trusts Mike or is this just like his
only last resort kind of play I think
it's still I think they're still early
in their relationship I think I think
what nacho does at the very end of the
season it's his way of showing mine it's
like if it was a romantic relationship
it was not you're showing that he's
willing to get married and have children
do you know what I mean it's like it's a
commitment it's a huge commitment and he
shows he doesn't do it for Gus he does
this for Mike you know he accepts to
frame Tony because he knows that he
feels in his heart that this is what
Mike wants him to do and it's his way of
showing Mike listen then I'm I will play
ball with you and I will go beyond what
is demanded from because I've already
given you bottle I've delivered a lot oh
I hope you put Lalo in jail and I've
driven Lalo myself back to Mexico so
just let me be you know
yeah and Mike kind of in a way through
these guys these assassins kind of asks
macho I need you to do this one more
thing and that and that's what this is I
think it's a leap of faith and his
relationship with Mike and saying this
and that you know if
had any doubt about me and my my
trustworthiness this is it right I'm all
go all the way you gotta hold your end
of the bark yeah that's that's really
interesting and I totally see that
Michael and I wondered - you mentioned
Gus in that and we see in this episode
that Gus actually references nacho to
being like a disobedient dog in a sense
but as you Michael mando do you see him
like yeah I mean do you see though like
does nacho do you think he ever sees
himself as like disobedient that sensor
is that just complete like that you know
what I mean for me it's it I think I
mean you could tell Mike's face when you
see that scene and they cut the mic and
Mike kind of looks at Gus like man this
guy's like beyond not hearing what he's
saying right now you can't call a human
being anything like that first of all
not shows a grown man you know he's not
he's not your child
you can't treat someone like that and
and that reveals more about you than
does about him but I think that's is a
mastermind I think is someone he's a
wonderful character played beautifully
by John Carl Estes you know a character
that I love and I admire John's work so
much but he's a guy who's kind of really
sold himself to this war and he's unable
to see life outside of his revenge plan
you know everything else is secondary to
him so that it's a bit of a sad
character in that sense that he's unable
to understand life outside of events and
sees not you as like an asset see
someone not show someone who's really
really valuable
right so no III think I think it's a
testament and Naturals courage and an
integrity for him to not allow another
human being to dictate his own fate and
I think it's a testament and not just
courage and heart that he's willing to
fight these corporations he's one man
against corporation you know most police
and my nose is like a billion dollar
corporation the cartel
like the most powerful organization in
the world in that part of the world you
know and this guy's willing to I don't
think stand up to them in the sense that
you know he can't battle these people
but he's willing to follow his heart and
do what's right and and get out and save
his father's money
I mean that except of course instead of
said Gus cuz he's an asset because so
when you're saying that to about like
this is something that he's trying to
save his father's life and he's really
like against the man in a sense if you
look at the GAR tell and Gus that way
and like when we see leading up to this
finale you know you feel terrible he's
made bad choices sorry I don't know I
don't want to sound like I'm I'm
thinking that just sound like completely
like he's got no part to play in it he's
made choices as a young man wanting to
be in the game and unfortunately he
wants out for the right reasons but just
destiny is making it incredibly hard and
he's got to go like beyond what is
required of him to get out so I don't
want to think Natura was too innocent
either you know he still is kind of
partly responsible for the situation no
yeah I think that's totally fair but
what you're saying though is like what
nacho with his motivations like if when
he's in this car with a lotto I think as
an audience we all really like nacho and
I think we root for him and we feel bad
for him but also especially I think just
having him on the opposite side of
someone like Lalo who's just an evil man
and he can't get away from him and I
just wonder in these scenes with Lalo
like when he's driving around in the car
and nacho so close to just dropping him
off can't get away why doesn't nacho
just shoot him per se or does he feel
like giving up at one point like what
are you what's your take on that you
know what what I love about not show and
it's really honestly it's a character
that has then I can't tell you how
emotional I get when I when I think
about this journey because I've spent so
much time in this guy's head and and so
much of it is nonverbal so you you
really got to dive so deeply into
yourself to try to understand and
everything seems like microseconds you
know he's always walking a razor edge
and it's it's
it's incredible because art informs life
and life informs aren't and I've grown
so much you know as a human being
playing that character I've I've learned
so much about myself and for me the
character is really becomes a man at the
end of this evening you know it's like
you receive the audit you know in the
Odyssey
Ulysses wants to go back home and at the
end of season five he goes to the heart
of the Death Star and he sits face to
face with the SEC you know the the Darth
Vader's master right and and and looks
them in the eye and kind of in a strange
way chooses to like he looks you know
the the Seth in the eye seems like Darth
Vader's boss and he says to him I want
out I want nothing to do with this I I
don't like you I don't like this game I
don't I don't want it I don't want to
try this game and I choose the light and
at the end of the season he's literally
running into the forest trying to find
home and I don't think home for nacho is
so much a physical place anymore I think
it's just become a sense of comfort
within themselves a place of redemption
where he can be one with his father's
love and at least if he died at least
that he dies looking out into the
horizon that he that he comes back home
in some way or another and that to me
it's just unbelievable you know to have
a character close so much over five
years and to change architects yes it's
just been so informative from the other
person you can tell I'm so passionate
and I just can't stop talking about it I
love when you come on because you you go
and it's just so fun to listen to and it
makes my work way easier so I appreciate
it but um I think you're just an awesome
interview in general but this is the
thing is like you're talking about him
running away and I had to say just as an
audience member and watching shows like
this and it comes from the Breaking Bad
universe where we see so many deaths
happen of big characters I just think
it's something for you that's awesome
that we've been with nacho since season
one like he's in our soul with better
call saw and there was a lot of people
predicting he would die in this for now
Ali hammer Kim and it's kind of just
been fluctuating between those two
because we don't know their status and
breaking bad and I'm wondering do you
feel like when you read the script for
season 5 that you had like a sense of
relief like holy God I've made it again
like I've keep going yeah I thought I
was gonna die in season 4 I remember I
spoke to Peter I said just tell me what
what episodes and and he said to me at
the beginning C's employee says not not
to see right and I had a talk with him
in season 5 and I have to say I really
thought it was going to happen at the
end of the season and when I read the
script when I read episode 9 and 10 it
created so much anxiety cuz I said to
myself how the hell can I how is not
your gonna solve all these storylines
you've got the girls at home you've got
the money and it's safe
you've got his father he needs to
convince you've got Gus you've got Lalo
who's gonna want to kill him you've got
done in la tuya who suddenly has like
this unbelievable interest in nacho and
according to Steve Bower was someone who
feels like nacho could potentially be
like the son he never had and then you
got the police on one side and this
guy's alone in the world
you know he's completely alone in the
world trying to do the right thing and
there's like you've got no help you know
so hopefully my eye sees what not so
good as a sign of loyalty that's what
that is you know macho not sure that
it's a mic right his way of showing my
came in like out go to the bottom I'll
go to the end of the world to show you
that I'm your guy
but you've got to do that for me too you
know you've got to show me that you're
my guy and you got to talk to your boss
and make him understand that like I've
paid my dues and more and it's time to
let me go with that in mind asking
Michael and away from just unbiased Lee
from nachos character you watching as a
viewer do you feel from seeing that
scene with how Gus reacted to Mike
basically asking to like let you out of
this thing
do you see hope and maybe season 6 that
nacho has any shot of getting out of
like Gus's grip or would you predict
just as a fan of the show like I don't
see it happening like
even feel about that man anxiety brother
I can tell you right now this is here's
what I love about all this is that it's
naturals in the hardest place that you
can ever imagine a character being I
mean he's literally got every every
powerful force in this Breaking Bad
universe the most powerful forces are
all pointing against him at the same
time you know you've got Gus fling the
greatest biggest you know mastermind in
the Breaking Bad universe yes you've got
Don Eladio you've got his own father and
Lalo Salamanca all pointing and saying
no not this way not this way not this
way and what's what's amazing and so
heartbreaking about this character is
he's really trying to do the right thing
he what he wants out he's done he
doesn't want to kill anybody he doesn't
want to hurt anybody he's not interested
in the money he doesn't want the power
doesn't want the influence doesn't want
the girls in the morning he wants to
live a pure life who wants to get out
and he wants his father to accept him of
his child again to the point that he's
willing to put all his money and buy his
father's shop so that his father can
retire you know it's it's so pretty and
and and beautiful and these riders are
amazing so yes II man I don't know what
absolutely and I think what makes nacho
such a you know character we can
sympathize with and what I believe
really was my most likable moment of
nacho in the season was actually in the
finale when you get the phone call to be
at the gate at 3:00 a.m. you know to
meet these assassins that Gus hired to
take out Lalo you know it's going down
but like there is a line here that
nachos like it's gonna be clean right
you know there's innocent people here
there's old people here to me that's
just amazing because it's like this guy
is literally just trying to get out of
this horrible situation he said so much
bad happened to him but he's still even
thinking of something like that so I
want to ask you as like with nacho how
does he justify in his head to still run
knowing that there's a good chance
innocent people will die when he opens
that gate I think he doesn't know III
don't think he opens the gate willingly
knowing what exactly is going to happen
okay but I think he believes this is
coming from Mike he really truly
believes this is Mike helping him out
this is Mike's not
30 Mike's helping him out but I think he
is at the service of Mike and the last
we seen nacho he tells Mike I'm out and
feels that Mike is potentially on his
side
and when he gets this call he says this
is coming from the one guy that I think
I can trust the only guy in this whole
universe that I can trust he's telling
me to do this and this is a guy who's an
ex-cop and at least on a subconscious
level we know that Mike had a son who
was trying to do the right things
probably about nachos inch and you and
not your things that men this guy's you
know if you put Mike if you draw Mike on
one paper and you fold the paper in half
and leave a mark on the other side
that's not just father they're like the
yin and the yang of naturals life
they're the same silhouette one is
standing in the light one is standing in
the dark but they're pretty much the
same they hold the same weight and then
mike is the potential guy that can help
him save his father
there's only don't that's the parallel
it's the only bridge between those two
worlds and whatever he does he does it
he does it to show Mike that this guy
that he's a hundred percent game and
hopefully Mike will really see that as
as a sign of profound loyalty and and
will understand it not only is not shows
trustworthy but he's totally on the same
wavelength as Mike and when natural
leaves when he runs out into the forest
I think that's when he finally earned
his lion crown you know his hair grows
out and and he's a full lion at that
point and he's a man among men and
standing on his own shoulder and it's
kind of like the journey back home yeah
and I mean that's what's so interesting
about it too is just so much anxiety
with nacho in this episode and the
finale and I wonder you know you talk
about how much his motivation is for you
know to save his father and get out of
there if his father wasn't alive do you
think nacho would have enough in his
tank to keep going and push through this
or what do you think he would have just
given up
that's an amazing question I don't know
it's so hard to imagine to answer that
question because it's like you're asking
me to imagine that the father dies right
and for me it's like I ask man that's I
I can't even think about that right now
I I just don't think about it you know
in dark times that's a that's a tough
man that's like man that's heartbreaking
I I don't miss much
let's just let's let's say Michael mando
didn't want to answer this I like this
he'd rather not think about that right
now
that's amazing so also the big line I
thought for nacho in this episode was
actually in the big moment when he's
sitting down with Don Eladio and they're
having a drink and Don Eladio asked him
you know what do you want and nacho says
respect make my own decisions I don't
want to be looking over my shoulder is
this totally truthful is this actually
what he's singing in that moment and can
you kind of delve more into what he
means by that Peter Gould you know who I
love I love piers and Peter said to me
before we were shooting he said to me
say it from the heart
he said mean it and then we started
rolling in Stephen Fowler who I
absolutely loved he said to me that he
sees natural as the son he never had you
know she's like a very able young man
and kind of noble and courageous and
feels like man this is the guy that can
that I that I want running my empire
because he clearly doesn't trust the
other guys you know but even asked to go
first you know usually when you're doing
a cover between two actors someone
sometimes so actually to sort of go for
some political second Stephen wanted to
go first and I of course I have to give
Stephen whatever he wants you know
Stephen as a veteran in this and someone
I respect very much like of course go
please do it and when we got to my
coverage Peter said to me said mean it
if it speaks from the heart say it like
you mean it and tell him the truth but
of course it's not the truth that he
understands that the audience and you
understand they
when we were shooting when we got to my
coverage the Sun was about the cents
because they had shot all the other
stuff that takes place in that location
in that morning and I was the last thing
that they were shooting in that location
and something incredible happened that I
don't know what it was but as the Sun
was setting the the set became so quiet
and I was looking at the skeeters eyes
and we heard there was a sound like a
very very soft sound during the whole
scene and it was a hummingbird and we
could hear the hummingbird slapping
while we were doing the scene and it was
like I felt like I was in a vortex you
know for a while I felt like we somehow
sort of was locked into the heart of
nacho and it was just like really gentle
place that's very very kind of like soft
enchanted world that was almost romantic
you know almost talked that moment was
really special for me and I'm really
grateful that Peter told me to play it
like that and I'm really grateful that
Stephen and I got along so well and that
he felt such a connection to the
character before he met me because he
was a fan of the show and that we had
such a strong connection you know he
texted me once in the middle of the
night saying you know let's go out it
was like chewy and I liked what I saw
sure to wrap things up Michael I just
wanted to bring up you are also in a
musician and you're launching this music
career you're doing you just released a
single the wild one which I have linked
down below in my info please check that
out can we expect a full album out of
this thank you so much this is an EP
that I I've been writing music my whole
life since I was eight years old I've
must have written over 2 300 songs maybe
250 maybe it's something like that and
then thousands of poems and I've been
singing my whole life and making music
my whole life and that's contributed a
lot of songs without releasing my name
and last year unfortunately while we
were shooting at
that my father had liver cancer and he
was Stage four and I remember walking
but it was crazy because I was shooting
a show where I had to save my father's
life and then I have to deal with it in
real life and at the time it was it was
like devastating to me and there's a
part of me that really wanted to keep it
totally private I felt like there was
such amount of shame that I couldn't do
anything and I felt like this isn't
something I haven't want to tell anybody
and then I realized that there's courage
in in accepting life and accepting your
fate and accepting that this is mortal
were part of a mortal existence and
we're all going to go and I remember
walking at night and seeing the live
performance and I was watching them and
I said to myself and may not give
anything it's like I just go next to
that bar and sit next to that guitar and
just sing with him and I walked home and
I stopped and I turn around I did it I
said I'm gonna do it I had a hat on
glasses on and I sang with him from like
11 p.m. to 3:00 in the morning and we
had a nice crowd gather around us
because we were next to a bar so they
could hear us and people were clapping
and cheering and all that kind of stuff
and I said to myself and it feels so
good and and I need to do that so I went
home and I wrote the write the wild one
which is either in the first verse I
mentioned my father and in the second
verse I mentioned my mother and then I
decided I was going to release a trilogy
so three songs and the wild one is the
emancipation it's heading into the
sunset and then the next song is that
I'm gonna release in a few weeks it's
going to be that you're in the depths
you're facing your demons and in the in
the heart of the forest and then the
third song you're you you're waking up
for the sunrise and it's so personal to
me and I felt so compelled to do it and
the response have been unbelievable I
just got a text from my publicist that
it's airing in Turkey and the songs
airing on the radio and stuff so yeah
check it out I hope you guys love it and
I hope you guys the next year yes I
check it on YouTube right now and it'll
be on the streaming services in a week
yes so right there the link to the
YouTube video is right under this video
what are you doing watch it next and
please if you haven't watched also catch
up to watch Michael
and Oh in it it's on Netflix it's on AMC
on demand check it out Michael thank you
so much for joining me and I hope to
have you on for a third time for season
six god bless you brother thank you so
much man have it going